"No Time to Die," Daniel Craig's
final outing as James Bond,
ties up a lot of loose ends from his
tenure onscreen as the renowned superspy.
When the dust settles, the day has been saved,
and this era of Bond has drawn to a close,
we still have some unanswered questions.
"No Time to Die" is a whopping two hours
and 45 minutes long with a 30 minute opening
sequence. The most stirring part of this
epic opening set piece comes when Bond,
at the behest of Madeleine Swann, visits the final
resting place of Vesper Lynd, the love interest
who betrayed him in "Casino Royale." Madeleine
wants to start a new life with James, and that
requires closing the chapters behind them.
For Madeleine, that means telling James all
the secrets she's never shared. But for James,
that means forgiving a dead woman he still loves.
When he gets to her grave, it's been
booby-trapped and explodes in his face,
setting his quest in motion and severing his
trust with Madeleine, who he now believes must
be Vesper 2.0, having lured him into this mess.
Later in the film, Blofeld confesses to Bond that,
as in "Spectre," he was the author
of this particular pain point,
knowing Bond would eventually visit her
tomb and that all he had to do was bide
his time. What's not explicitly spelled out
is just how long he had been planning this.
At that point in the film, Blofeld has been in
prison for half a decade, so did he have his
long-distance henchmen rig up the cemetery with
explosives even before he wound up incarcerated?
Or were his men on the outside just keeping tabs
on Bond in the hopes an emotional ultimatum in
his relationship would lead to him being
at the right place at the wrong time?
The film's opening flashback reveals a fuller
portrait of a plot point originally revealed
in "Spectre": That Madeleine's mother was
killed by one of her father Mr. White's
enemies while she was a child hiding upstairs.
Here, we see that the enemy was new Bond
villain Lyutsifer Safin, played by Rami Malek.
We find out Safin himself had his own family
brutally slaughtered by White, so his revenge
was inevitable. But when Madeleine-as-a-child
fights back against his attack and he chases her
to the point she collapses under a frozen lake,
Safin chooses to rescue her. In present
day, after the five-year time jump,
Safin reappears in Madeleine's life and makes
her an unwitting pawn in his master plan,
making it clear he's been obsessed
with her since that fateful day.
"You don't know what this is."
But the film is built around the premise
that the full details of their connection will
prove devastating to James. In a way, they do,
because Madeleine and James have lost years of
their lives not even speaking because the plot's
circumstances convinced him she wasn't to be
trusted, which couldn't be further from the truth.
We just never find out more about Safin and
Madeleine's connection. He must have taken her
to safety after retrieving her from under the ice,
but did he help raise her for a time? He claims to
have kept a close watch on her over the years, but
was she ever aware? Was there more to this shared
history, or was it all just a misdirect?
After appearing in both "Casino Royale" and
"Quantum of Solace" as franchise stalwart Felix
Leiter, Bond's American bestie, played by Jeffrey
Wright, was nowhere to be seen in the ensuing two
sequels. He returns here as the catalyst for
much of the film's plot, and when he does,
Leiter and Bond seem even closer and chummier than
they did when he was still a brand new 00-agent.
This mission the two men embark on together proves
to be their last, as Leiter dies in front of Bond,
drowning and suffering from gunshot
wounds from fellow spook Logan Ash,
who betrayed them both. It proves to be
one of the film's most affecting moments,
largely because of the palpable
chemistry between Craig and Wright.
Bond being an international agent, it's presumed
he and Leiter worked on many, many unseen missions
in between his last appearance and this
film, but we still wonder what he was
up to as a rogue former MI6 agent ran amok in
"Skyfall" and as Spectre became such a powerful
force for terrorism.
In a key moment in the film, Safin uses a
kidnapped MI6 scientist to alter a weaponized
disease Blofeld was planning to use to kill Bond,
making it backfire and kill every living member
of Spectre. This happens at a ball thrown for
the evil organization, with Blofeld, in prison,
attending via the connection from his bionic
eye to a mirrored one out in the real world.
When Bond has to explain to M that Blofeld has
been orchestrating Spectre activities from behind
bars using his bionic eye, M explains that no one
sees or speaks to Blofeld all day outside of his
therapist, Madeleine. But how did MI6 not notice
this man had a cybernetic science fiction eyeball
for the last five years?
The film's primary MacGuffin is Project Heracles,
a bioweapon designed to only affect genetically
marked targets. MI6 was developing it as an
off-the-books program that would make missions
simpler and risk fewer field agents' lives.
Somehow, M is surprised when it's stolen by
Spectre, then Safin's upstart operation, and
repurposed as a weapon of mass destruction.
In the film's climax, Safin's island, existing
in a nebulous, ungoverned space between Russia
and Japan, must be destroyed to stop Project
Heracles from being deployed globally.
"He's going to kill millions."
M struggles to navigate the quagmire
strategically, because England can't be seen
as instigating an international incident,
especially when the impetus behind it would
reveal gross negligence on their part.
So when the dust cleared, how did M
avoid catastrophic geopolitical blowback
after destroying this island with missiles?
As the remaining cast eulogizes the fallen,
it certainly appears M still has his job,
so he must have executed some true
diplomatic finesse to keep his head.
When "No Time to Die" and its lengthy credits
finally crawl to a close, the film's closing
message is that "James Bond will return..."
But not only is Daniel Craig not returning for
another film, his iteration of James Bond meets an
untimely end in a tragic scene of self-sacrifice
in the movie's final act. We know how this goes.
New Bond actor usually means new Bond continuity,
but we're in uncharted territory now
that we have a canonical Bond film
that shows the hero dying at the end.
So with Lashana Lynch's Nomi most likely
reclaiming her official designation as 007 after
temporarily relinquishing it to Bond on his last
mission, will she return in another film? Just
because the next Bond film will probably start
from scratch doesn't mean this particular world
can't continue in a spinoff sequel, especially
given the warm reception to Lynch's performance
and Phoebe Waller-Bridge's exceptional writing.
Folks have been clamoring for a female Bond
or a Black Bond in recent years, but perhaps
now that Lynch has done such a fine job with
Nomi, a Black female 007, why not give her a
solo film devoted to fleshing her out further?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about
"No Time to Die" are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.